hello and welcome to the Sun video
playing frankly and see what we get here
um Queens gambit probably yes three wins
zero losses to draw so that's a pretty
decent squad I came so I place it that
is gaining popularity recently that move
maybe I can play some kind of Catalan
setup I think yeah the system the best
line probably against this grabbing the
pawn yeah well it will probably be some
okay some position body tries to tries
to keep the pawn before it's probably
going to go five hmm I don't quite see
how I get the porn back at the moment
92,000 I'd be six so this is not
happening 95 also bad maybe this one
people controlling me five preparing 95
it takes it and now at x f4 yeah now I
probably have to t have to cover this
even though it's not clear how i'm
getting the poem back it's really really
not obvious
maybe 495 here that is going come into
before I guess I have to try to get it
back I mean it's really even ok so let's
see for you will take and play the
bishop ok interesting hmm that's
interesting ok a forearm loses a pawn
that's not good takes III take a 40 even
though doesn't feel entirely clear I
cannot take see forces which is quite
irritating i can i can try to prepare
that covering be five so now let's see
for is an idea clean before i can
probably take on the center ok so we're
appealing he insists on preparing all
this i see i can go night before here in
this position just
with this one maybe hmm I rather
interesting see going for Bishop b5 now
maybe
yeah maybe there should be five now it's
not not so bad no so opening up the
position okay the damn a bit surprised
bit surprised about I can take this and
I think I'll do that i'll get the pawn
back now i think i can be i'm happy that
i get it back and think about the
details later because the remaining um
position should be quite okay i'm
controlling the see file here and it's
not not easy for them to play this
position my bishops is also quite strong
there on g2 a bit surprised that he took
that ok it's it wasn't easy to play in
the first place I mean I thought 94
maybe what's bad of it no not easy to
say the m95 looks very normal or bring
the king i think i'll i'll activate the
King here let's not take take right I
don't see one yeah 95 was an option or
is an option here looks very normal
let's do it even though i'm not quite
sure what I'm threatening maybe he is
still totally fine here
I mean it's it's always slightly
annoying i'm looking at that too that
porn down f7 but i'm not quite positive
when I'm threatening this is the thing I
mean it looks kind of nice why but what
is my threat don't quite see that i
don't think i have a threat here in this
version back to c5 is that no better I
mean 97 doesn't lead anywhere rookie
seven I don't I don't see this leading
to much
yeah maybe really back to see five after
yes played b5 it really is a different
situation with the with the bleep I'm
being played and c5 beam week now yeah
don't do it that trans much 97 maybe
you
okay covered that one I can do this now
though check a five and then over to
deform here we'll probably okay no
energy for its not a problem Rock d7
might be no didn't do that
hmm I wonder before I said something I
would love to I would love to play
Bishop everyone but it's got 9594 as the
thing maybe this one fixing the pawn and
if he takes rook takes before I thought
nights is six but not sure about it down
I'm threatening f3 now and Bishop f1
this would basically win the b5 pawn so
I think he has to take nightman 9696 I'm
sorry I don't I'm I'm from happening
this okay while really really a
overlooking many things here yeah but
now this is Bishop f1 is a very serious
threat out for Rupe c5 now and think
this will be difficult difficult to
cover the right to shoot 45 okay
probably i'm not sure if I've maybe if I
first want as much pressure as possible
I think this should be should be pretty
strong Lucas is six coming check check
it should win now check my dresser
irritate me time one sec forfeits on
time okay tough game I think it was okay
for him for quite a while this year is a
it's somewhat better i think for white I
was this porn down and I'm really not
sure if there was any any super clear
compensation often you have some but
it's it's oh it's difficult for me to
assess if this is enough or not I mean
this look kind of normal I was surprised
at c5 I mean about 25 this was what I
expected and I really really wasn't sure
what what I'm doing there this would be
nice but he has got c3 here and I don't
know if I like that maybe it's not so
bad I can go back I know maybe I have
some compensation but it's it's kind of
its kind of doubtful i think ok i am i
was happy to just get the pawn back and
now have a somewhat better position
Quincy five I wasn't even the best yeah
man I have six is stronger jack is a
stronger yeah G takes I take t5 and
Knight takes Queen c7 is pretty awful
yeah ok so that's would have been even
better ok this is not not that great I
mean I i can try because my bishop is
still stronger piece but it's nothing
it's nothing special and I'm going back
to try to do something against the ports
I don't know somewhere before here maybe
when probably is that my king is also
participating and sometimes you can just
feel find that white is playing with
this extra King in a way doing some jobs
and black em sometimes just lose this
one of those queenside pawns in the
instructure like that okay decided to go
for passive plan before no I think
what's good fixing that porn and I think
he has to take now and try this position
even though it doesn't look particularly
great this is what the what the engine
wants to do just to just to show Oh f3
this is the computer line with a clear
advantage for white okay so that sense
it's winning actually I don't know here
it's gay he is critical I think
definitely and this I think should be
very nice for wide maybe you can just
about hold Lukas is seven hours and is
an option when I cannot take here
because like book wrap here so which the
cell I probably take my channel for 90 x
and e 40 k white is better but am i
winning who not easy not easy to say
it's very borderline somewhere between
winning and better for wide probably
said if I've is forcing one night to
move and then I'll get b5 something like
this is still not easy to win because
black has come to play yeah white is
better here because of the bishop the
bishop dog will support one of the
passes him it's not clear though that it
is a win
yeah this is very nice now check check
white has a completely dominating
position with ruined bishop and I worked
his seven I could have played okay now I
saw this and I thought it would win so I
didn't look any further but look t7s
simple of course this was my leg the
line that I saw but I didn't see it's
actually that he can get this it might
still be enough because my pawns will be
supported by a bishop and this Bishop is
dominating the light a bit at the moment
well it's not clear it's not a totally
clear business yeah when I was a winning
on time this was also one one point I
didn't really look that that hard
knowing that the time is in my favor
okay hope you enjoyed the video thanks
for watching